And the answer is, none of them. This is more than
just a trick question. The point I'm trying to make, is
that all of these browsers are a little different. And if
you've used more than one of them, you'll know that, that's
obviously true. However, none of these browsers are perfect. And in
fact, it's not even clear when we're doing web development what
perfect is. It, it's a very imperfect art the web design
is. And so, while you may have a preference for one
of these browsers, it is not necessarily true that your
users agree. You know, you may like Chrome, and your
users may prefer Internet Explorer. Or more realist, realistically, you
may like Chrome, and your users are forced to use Internet
Explorer. So you need to have in mind that all
of these browsers are different. They all behave differently. And
you need to keep that in mind as you as
you develop and test in as many browsers as you can.